howdy if you manage to stay awake in
your high school biology class you might
remember the central dogma of molecular
biology
it states that DNA makes RNA and that
RNA serves as a template for assembling
kameena acids into proteins according to
the genetic code however what your
biology teacher may not have told you is
that some bacteria assemble certain mini
proteins without using an RNA template
for example some antibiotics molecular
bullets that bacteria used to kill other
bacteria and mini proteins that do not
rely on the genetic code and instead use
an even more complex non-ribosomal code
in this class we will see that to crack
this non-ribosomal code we first need to
learn how to compare giant proteins
responsible for the production of
antibiotics in bacterial cells if we
don't align these proteins correctly
then the elusive hidden message
revealing the non-ribosomal code will
disappear this is just one of many
problems in modern biology that relate
to sequence comparison to learn how to
align sequences of individual genes and
proteins we will take a sightseeing
detour to Manhattan and after comparing
individual genes we will zoom out to
compare entire genomes containing
billions of nucleotides we will see that
for nearly every human gene there is a
mouse analog however these genes oq' in
very different arrangements on the human
in Mouse Ramazan these arrangements
differ because our genomic architecture
has been shaped by rare and powerful
mutations called genome rearrangements
you can think of genome rearrangement as
a genomic earthquake that moves around
huge chunks of DNA often from chromosome
to another rearrangements also often
shuffle cancel genes for example some
types of leukemia are characterized by
exchanging
like genomic segments between
chromosomes 9 and 22 by learning exactly
where this rearrangement happens
scientists developed a miracle drug
called Gleevec that has saved the lives
of thousands of leukemia patients now
we're in California here where
earthquakes occur much more often than
in most other places on the planet so
our question that we were going to are
going to ask is there's a similar
phenomenon occur with genomic
earthquakes in other words are the
breakage points of genome rearrangements
scattered throughout the human genome
with no apparent rhyme or reason or do
they occur at fragile regions or genomic
fault lines where this breakage is
occurring over and over again if yes
where are these fragile regions in the
human genome and how do they relate to
cancer we hope that you're going to join
us to decipher the non-ribosomal code
and look for these fragile regions in
the human genome
although these instructors may appear
crazy they are not quite as mad as they
look dr. Pavel peb snare is a
distinguished professor of computer
science at the University of California
San Diego and a leading authority on
bioinformatics he's dressed this way
because he sometimes thinks that he's a
sheriff of bioinformatics a frontier
discipline underpinning the digital
revolution in biology and personalized
medicine dr. Phillip Campo is an
assistant professor of computer science
at Carnegie Mellon University to learn
why he is dressed this way you'll need
to take this course or read the textbook
bioinformatics algorithms an active
learning approach co-authored by the two
speakers